hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to your walk well we're
in a different place than we were before
and I apologize for that I started
playing and I did my intro and
everything but I was not recording so I
looked like an idiot
and I dragged the fire already into this
hovel which means that you guys didn't
get to experience the intro this lovely
music and I apparently didn't notice
that the river back there with a horse
was is now filled with blood which is a
lovely touch on the whole place but
either way I already went in here and I
was already shocked at how creepy it was
but one thing I did notice is that these
symbols that are listed like right here
and right there on there they but they
were the ones where there were the ones
that were on the trees and I've been
writing it all down on my little notepad
here so I need to find a way how this
relates to what I need and that is a
dead bird that is that is definitely a
dead bird over there so anyway let's
explore this area and see if it gives us
any insight as to what we need to do
that seems like that wait I don't know
if I know that one but they seem to be
giving them a number so I'm assuming
that that's some sort of order hmm aha
okay so that one is that simple I have
not seen that yet but that means that
that is number one so let me write that
down and find the accompanying thing
outside I guess one second right along
ah there are all the figures all the
figures are over there and that means
that is number six that's the only one
that I haven't seen besides I've got
four down here on my list that's number
six so that must be last I don't know
what symbol that is but it can only be
so many my process of elimination should
be fine can I interact with those No
well okay this is cool and all but what
am I supposed to do about all this I
could have sworn that this led to
another area I must have to solve the
puzzle and I should be able to move
forward then do I pull you down okay
chicken foot is number three god it's
like I can't do anything and it's really
kind of creepy being in here I can't
click and drag why do I do huh how do I
do
oh whoa whoa okay oh we found the bloody
area I did not know this went farther
right
all right then things got fun real quick
that's the cent sign so that's number
four that's related to the girl I think
that the girl figurine oh I'm glad we
got to the bloody area that's my
favorite thing in horror games this game
was a lot more horror than I thought it
was gonna be I don't know what I was
expecting but it's very highly rated in
apparently the people have been sick
okay well that's good I got that is I
mean I can finally go to where I need to
go to go to the place with the other
symbol yes yes absolutely what am I
looking at there okay big tree or big
rock that's a dead bird did you take my
key oh you have my key give me my key
back man
stop Oh
what the hell what are we playing off
okay well thank you for that I'll take
that he's gonna melt oh I can actually
hold it wait a minute there's yes that's
that that thing okay I got to write that
down because that's important and I
gotta know what those symbols what the
other symbols mean I don't know okay so
this goes pretty crazy over there up and
deluge okay got that one so I'm gonna
take the key with me back down the
ladder hope nothing bad happens
isn't that just a lovely wish to have oh
it sparkles and gives off light and hope
to all the children of the world or
probably means my death that may be that
why do I need to do this anyway why in
the world do I need to do any of this
well as an interesting sound I love how
the music chains and the theme would
change every single time I leave Deus
accomplish something it changes it
changes the whole mood of it but I got
one last symbol here so god the
immersion of the story in just the
mystery what the hell is going on I
don't know what that symbol that I did a
bad thing
oh whoa that I should be writing that
down huh good double arrow okay double
arrow to the right
oh god I'm doing bad double arrow to the
left double arrow to the right oh okay
I'm with it I'm with it huh it's like
the owl thing the hooter bumper to get
eaten by the crazy forest lady that's
what I did okay come on well okay what
are you trying to tell me all right I
got it written down it's just alternate
no no two rights and then left and right
okay well that is so cool you don't even
know how cool that is
don't know what the hell to do with that
information trying to tell me that you
know what are you doing reality you do
not okay open ye gates allow me to cross
forward to where I need to go
this game was very important to pair
keys don't usually dissolve locks but
hey you know it's all good it's all good
if I can
ooh those look like sim balls oh wait I
have these wait a bit Oh were those the
only four in the woods then this must be
give me clues two more ooh okay all
right then oh no I didn't get all the
order I've got some of the order I don't
have all the order that means there's
got to be some symbols like in there
whoa okay chill out there was not ready
for that
ah oh oh oh oh so this is four dots the
horse he was I don't know how many dots
but the baby was I don't know how many
dots but the bird was definitely three
dots uh-huh so that means those must be
some and some are the arrows over there
I don't know but that's cool so I got to
get to the goat but the goat is the
go-to symbol I don't know it's goat is I
don't know I don't know what the goat is
I don't know what that is I don't know I
wish I did
maybe I can guess hmm I feel like
anything else is just wandering around
aimlessly but I really wish I knew I
feel like I'm missing something here I
feel like I'm missing a secret or an
easter egg or something along those
lines either way okay it's possible that
that was the arrangement and that means
that the baby is too so I know for a
certain the bird is three the girl is
four and the baby is two only mean that
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa no no no I
why does that church have a face on it
huh why does a sure why oh boy oh wow I
don't go I got I've had it oh oh oh
the arrows okay so okay so I need to
make a full okay so uh ah that's what it
was that's what it was okay so all the
way left Cuba no sugar the sugar the
sugar the sugar the sugar the sugar the
sugar do all the way right sure buddy
show me the shovel to shovel to shovel
to shovel the sugar home BAM all the way
left right twice that's what it was I
had this information I just didn't know
what it went to so I thought I was
missing something what is this other
symbol the symbol in blood the symbol in
blood with five what does that even mean
I did it did I do good am I gonna see
the future now I got a welcome back
hi so you're the goat I've heard so much
about can move can't do anything
why do I do I have to unbutton your coat
for you oh I see Oh what uh I don't I'd
rather not
you know buts the only option that I got
what the hell why am I doing this maybe
that's what the symbol meant five I've
already hit way more than five why am I
doing this really why would I do this to
see the future okay what the hell oh
whoa whoa
oh okay
okay and I think I'm doing good I don't
know 100 I see what I'm new now I'm sure
what the hell that meant whoa hi
it's too late now
why it's too late for y1 the world is
that
oh my god
what am I looking at here there's like
shapes inside of it but not on the
outside come on come on trying to get to
you okay there's you I don't know what
you are are you
can I do anything about this there's
another puzzle whoa whoa whoa we will
weave oh well all right then
whoa the horsey is that my symbol all
right then I guess I'm traversing
through the different things that
symbols constellations even it can't be
changed the house my house
maybe I should have put those in some
soda order I feel bad
okay I'll do it in numerical order hey
yo that's what you liked and now the
baby this is just I don't even
understand the decision has already been
made what decision decision I don't get
it
you
I still don't know what the hell the Box
men I didn't I never figured out the box
how could I was there some information
that I definitely missed now the bird
have cost the bed what else could it be
you must stop coming here how many times
have I been there and now the goat I
don't understand the goat is out that is
oh you don't like that you don't like
being touched
I don't love
you any whoa winter is over
am i playing now I am I see the windmill
in the distance over there they're good
I don't have a map anymore so I can't
exactly look where I was I go forward
and backwards I don't know where am I
going
wait I see rocks no okay there's the
windmill again or is that a different
hello hi lady
how are you doing oh no no that's not
good that Oh
the sea and lastly an Ashland why why
I'm sorry okay excuse me I missed the
part where why
bring it all down I don't know if it
happened I don't know it can be changed
okay what deliver the message the
journal
the secret is hidden whose it's the
secret
north of the mill north of the mill I
didn't even know there was a north of
the mill south of the brook so there's
more and then there north of the mill
south of the rook
north of the mill salzillo brook north
of the mill south of the brook how could
it be schibler North Mill South Brook my
favorite place to go yes yes I will walk
again i'ma walk again there's something
more to be seen here and I'm gonna find
it north of the mill south of the brook
it must be related to that box it has to
be how do I open the box what's in the
box
I must know what's in the box there's
something north of Mill the wood the oal
ooh the journal ah oh yes that's what
this was it was locked it was like
username and password
oh it says right there on the side north
of the mill south of the brook I I
didn't know six 8 1894 connecting to
wifey Theodore okay this is off like oh
well then seven beginning it hello new
system testing photo upload it works
should probably right here more often
read about every book on Swedish
folklore there is surprised how little
has been written about year walking need
more sources of information talk to ESU
suggest some fieldwork might be good but
I feel that I might be thirty years too
late been talking to elderly folks
eating cookies and drinking coffee their
knowledge about your walking has been
limited to say the least
barely any one of them know knew what it
was if they did they had heard stories
its children but forgot the details
thinking yes sent me on some wild
excited the newspapers finally mention a
Daniel Svendsen he was apparently
arrested for the murder of a young woman
in bed trip information is scarce
her name is steena Nielsen and she was a
miller's daughter her body was found on
a field outside of
village she had been stabbed multiple
times the library should it be open
longer hope I can find any reference to
the supposed weird year walk September
11th the motive behind the murder seems
to have been jealousy the motive behind
the murder seems to have been jealousy
not many details
apparently steena was going to marry a
lukas tapper she was on her way home
from Lucas's parents when she was
intercepted by Daniel
she was found the following morning just
17 years old I feel it sad guilty about
my excitement yesterday after all there
is a great tragedy behind all this the
press not sleep too excited by files
much of the records are of a legal
nature but there are relevant passages
Daniel claimed he knew that he would
murder Steen after seeing it in a vision
on his year walk sadly the scribe has
not bothered to take it all down and
occasionally just refers to his
ramblings of a madman poor boy there are
certain elements that are new to me must
write them down in detail later on need
fresh air Daniel's cabin solo sortin is
briefly mentioned in the protocol we'll
ask around about it hope it still exists
drove around for hours there's a box
it's the box
these woods are to get lost in ask for
directions most people never heard of it
was about to give up made him old man
his aunt lived in there till 60s had
three different odors used it as summer
house last family owned it as cam and
only stayed there one summer
five-year-old son drowned in a brook
nearby and after that they never
returned nobody's lived there since old
man's nephew owned the land I asked the
old man if I could pay a visit he did
not think there could be anyone that
would wind cabins situate deep in the
forest no road no scientists and narrow
paths start as here walk hundred years
ago felt overwhelmed by the thought
could not enter lonely place the only
other building I could find was
underground storehouse guess a month to
belong to the cabin too dark to see
anything couldn't imagine there would be
anything of significance back to the car
found a strange box
well not thing to leave in the forest
seems to be more or less mint condition
could not resist taking it tonight any
whisky and lots of it went to found the
box when I unpacked had almost forgotten
about it seems to have some sort of lock
like construction but I have only
understand exactly what it is or how it
is mind me one of those puzzle boxes the
wheel is open by entering a password
must be old decide not to tell yes about
the box he might not appreciate that I
took it with me he's nagging me about
six busy week classes meetings had the
weirdest dreams ever since I came back
from bed torpe dreamt that I was in a
vast wasteland I was searching for the
keys to my locker with together with
Jenny from high school we laughed and
dug in the sand suddenly the sky lit up
and Jenny pointed to a simplest
constellation of stars she whispered in
my ear to never forget it
I asked her what it meant what she said
but she was dead and her bones were
withered and old woke up and have been
feeling rather queasy since way received
an odd two email today got over a
thousand of these during last night the
email seemed to have stopped when my
inbox is full some kind of thread called
the priest told him of my plight he said
that ved TWRP sometimes had a strange
effect on people but it rarely lasted do
not think he understands I was going to
ask him about the box but decided to
hang up and he suggested I should see
someone woke up last night heard baby
screams from beneath the floorboards
panics to manage to pry up some of the
floorboards the screaming stopped you're
walking works but it was never meant to
it's against the rules the universe
blinked its eye and someone crossed all
barriers that are known as time and
space the watches are watching but who
are watching the Watchers how can you
bend time and space I've been an idiot
someone is playing with me
these shapes it's the same as on the box
did someone see me take it tried the
symbols I've received the box remains
shut there must be more coming telephone
rang answered could not hear anyone hung
up and rang again answered could hear
someone speak on the other side could
not make out what was being said the
voice was too far away hung up it kept
ringing cut the cord wish I had not cut
the cord to my phone need to hear a
human voice don't dare go out at first I
didn't even notice one of the paintings
in my living room has been replaced that
is disturbing must have been during the
30 minutes I slept can I let my guard
down someone was here or something
the antibiotics continued for me and I
am virus in the eye of the universe
boarded up the balcony in all the
windows nothing can come in now
shouldn't be possible but someone was
here again I'm definitely being
threatened there was a knife on my
kitchen table old but sharp what is
happening feel like a worm under a big
boot
I feel the shadow hanging over me
waiting to get crushed she sings and I
shall fall oh she's trying to fool me
that I know but I must get closer to her
because then I get closer to the key
that leads to the heart of it all I
didn't steal the box because it begged
me to take it with me
Daniel survived all the Watchers sent by
the universe he was lured by the
temptress brought to the innocence to
the pit brought the innocence to the
pale horse unearthed the parasite
finally faced a master of them all but
Yeti was destroyed could it have gone
any other way was he doomed from the
start
am I doomed this future said er can it
be altered in the end it was the nature
of man that got Daniel but free myself
from all desires that's how they get to
you can love really be a weakness or is
it a strength and the poor girl just
seems unfair is there anything I can do
if the future can be altered why not the
past am i playing the part of the fool
in the cosmic play and if so to what
purpose disconnected the microwave oven
just in case feeling absolute terror the
possibility that there is no purpose no
rhyme no reason to any of it why me
saw her lifeless body she is beautiful
even in death I've been crying ever
since it all seems so needless so cruel
ready for anything don't care anymore
it's finally here the last one woke up
with this on my palm tried to wash it
out it's a tattoo tested them in all
different combinations but I could not
figure out how to do it I must leap will
open that box tomorrow of course so
simple rotate the wheel and release when
the symbol aligns with the grim in the
order they were delivered to me but why
was it empty I still know not understand
who sent the symbols if it was not the
boy then it must have been the Watchers
but why they toying with us helping us
in some perverse twisted way from the
get-go he was doomed they got him at the
very thought of year walking but I sent
the girl he can be saved I put
everything he needs in the box and
locked it I will leave it where I found
it we're all this started if my mind is
set on this does it mean that I am
doomed
- the rift is open it wants me to go
through pack my things I wonder if I'll
ever come back just a picture when mill
Sorrell stood here which I could light a
fire I must do it right
surprise how calm I am only hours
remaining it's midnight that's the last
one so the box this is to make any sense
god this is a puzzle that's like itching
at my brain I have to solve this as his
gotta when they aligned with the Grimm
in the order that they were received the
journal the first one was a triangle he
ordered that they were received
that's another symbol that's a symbol
that's another one so it's a sideways
moon and the box the box is the next one
okay
box triangle that was the next symbol
the right-side up triangle and the last
one is like the moon on his palm there
it is there it is okay the upside down
the smiley face if you like okay so
that's it that's it then I know all of
them then okay so the first one is the
upside down triangle that would be the
one and then next one is just this D
here in the box the box right side up
triangle then last one should be old
people that one
it opened oh my god it opened oh my god
it opened I opened it I opened it god
that whole journal was like a freaking
crispy Chris creepypasta crispy possib
was executed ah
Wow who's found guilty for the heinous
murder of young Steen and Nielson last
year the death sentence has been
criticized by the highly renowned Elmer
loon Bach who stated that Daniel is
suffering from AM normal psyche seems to
have problems discerning passed from
president has visions of terrible
creatures something not uncommon among
schizophrenic s' cannot be held
responsible for his actions
he'll be given treatment excuse and was
performed by Gustav Dahlberg the fourth
execution last year was performed the
execution with the notorious Lisa
Rasmussen who was charged with the
murder of four
infants invent orb but who took her own
life before the sentence could be
carried out Wow
Daniel Svendsen was composed during the
whole process besides a slightly shaking
hands so common among criminal type you
could not tell Daniel from any other
young men he sobbed loudly when he was
laid his head down low but quickly
regained his composure a quick prayer
and a swift powerful stroke and it was
over I should have killed myself then
none of this would happen what holy cow
you are long dead when I write this and
I have not yet been born yet we have a
connection beyond life death space and
time the impossible made possible by
year walking but the Watchers always win
even though you've not passed through
the rift yet they sense the urge and
they want their sacrifice
I wish there could be another way I am
sorry but for her there's still hope you
can save her you know what you must do
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
all a crap Ola
oh okay here's a summation of what
happened because I know I'll have to cut
out stuff when I was reading on that
journal there was a lot of pages like 50
minutes of straight reading it was a
great read you guys got to play this
game just to read all of that but here's
what happened the guy in the future
whoever was looking into your walking he
was discovering the story of Daniel
Svendsen Daniel's fencing was the
character that I was playing in the game
but he was trying to year walk to try to
see the future he was the guy that was
talking to the girl there that was
telling him not to your walk the girl
there in the windmill was the one that
he killed and he killed him he killed
her because when a year walk his mind
was like lost to the fabric of time and
space and he was just wandering for eons
and eons but this guy in the future he
discovered about it he took the box and
discovered about you're walking and felt
a connection to the Daniel Svendsen and
when he was finally able to open the box
after you got sent the messages I don't
even know who sent the message he kept
going on about the Watchers of the
universe and compared them to antibodies
in the in the universe of the people or
things or creations or whatever have you
that fix the problems and he was getting
messages he got it sent a knife by
someone I don't know who maybe another
year Walker from a hundred years in the
future who knows but he got the messages
that he needed to help Daniel Svendsen
help himself and not kill the girl that
apparently he loved
holy cow that is awesome story if you
even comprehend that a little bit girl
it's confusing as hell but God that is
incredible that was awesome that was
amazing I love that I love that that's
fantastic
so anyway holy crap this was an awesome
mind-bending experience I love it when
things just the mystery is so
unbelievably interesting that you can't
help but pursue it it's so well done all
that was beautiful to go back into it
and then find a journal but the only
thing that kind of detached from it is
that you the player are playing as
Daniel Svendsen but you the player have
to see the clues maybe you're the year
Walker that tells the other guy the
clues that he needs to who knows
me that's what I got to do right now I
gotta go send some emails and send
somebody a knife if you know what I mean
and replace someone's painting in his
house but either way that was awesome
there's still a few under answered
questions I think like just with some
shapes that I don't recognize and shapes
that I haven't seen like I don't know I
don't know is there another mystery here
I don't know but I don't have time to
figure it out now so if you guys know
something else about this game that I
haven't discovered please let me know in
the comments below thank you all so much
for watching and you should give this
game a try seriously it's available on
Steam if you want it and either way
thanks everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
piece of old cloth rock
so anyway we
shores of New Jersey and the snow Native
Americans came out of their legs up
nerds nice belt under camera right let's
get with you